we are on patrol with the largest Muslim
rebel group in Mindanao the Moro Islamic
Liberation Front or mi LF for decades
they fought for independence tens of
thousands were killed but since the
self-proclaimed Islamic state burst onto
the scene in 2017 the Muslim rebels have
joined forces with a Philippine Army
both sides feel threatened by is
fighters now laying low the Muslim
minority strongly supports the mi LF
only 5% of Filipinos are Muslims and
almost all live in Mindanao their areas
are among the poorest in the Philippines
many here blame the Christian majority
government for their plight
[Music]
we visit the military headquarters of
the mi LF the government needs the rebel
support to secure peace and to fight
terror president Rodrigo Duterte has
promised them a far-reaching autonomy
the chief of staff isn't in uniform a
sign perhaps of the shift from
insurgency to politics the mi LF has
seen defectors joining is we asked him
what might happen if the autonomy
project goes badly our credibility to
our people will become diminished then
that's the time that the ISIS will take
advantage the situation
dopamine's all the powers of mi left to
join to their group and that time the
threat will become bigger he tells us
that they will disarm up to 30,000
fighters but only with full Muslim
autonomy what if not then the status
will remain we will not decommission our
forces and we will not also give up our
firearms which we promised to the
government this is what both sides are
trying to avoid another murabbi the
largest Muslim city of the Philippines
lies in ruins bombed out after a few
hundred is fighters had occupied Marathi
for five months two years ago more than
1000 people were killed tens of
thousands remain displaced
it was president - Tara - who ordered
the bombing but he is also a strong
supporter of Muslim autonomy his former
peace advisor tells us it is a strong
signal to the bad guys that don't play
around with this country I have been in
the peace process
under several precedents and we have not
moved it as far as we have this time the
president feels that we can improve as a
nation if we try to give more authority
and power to the locals but it must be
under one flag the Philippine flag but
if the autonomy drive fails more
disaffected Muslims could join radical
outfits in addition after the loss of
their Caliphate in Syria and Iraq more
foreign I as fighters might also decide
that Mindanao is the new front